ну ви знаєте мені здається що це ну як
б шантаж з боку Росії
якийсь жаль може викликати ну в
принципі я сьогодні дивилася її пісню
непогана
в вона інвалід і теж трав і банани
праворуч учасники, що підійшли
де олімпійські та параолімпійські ігри
але тільки з саша їх поїдати ти чого нас
інвалідності але я висловлюватися добрий рахунок
тебе показують люди з оголеними
можна владі ламають такі самі можна
вас втрачати її люди звучала на мій погляд
взагалі це не зовсім чесно коли
різновагові категорії без усяких як
б негативних емоцій до цієї дівчини
просто сама ситуація не зовсім
справедливо я світова аудиторія швидше
їй якраз на доріжку скажемо так
вистрілить не буде об'єктивно оцінювати
та його вокальні там здібності чи й
якість її музичного номера
негативно тому, що воно відразу буде
жаль викликати і ось відразу стояти
вище і якісь бали має ж Росія
викликати почуття жалю печалі знаєте
ось що ось але це все таки pr якийсь
адже всьому права притиснута ніхто там не
терористи тоді ж не знаю питання
спірний я не можу засуджувати тут сильно
продовжуємо ще артисти ванною завалюємо
ніби були відмінними це може так само вона
своїми піснями радість саме сеппо зад
і хтось думаю що немає ну як би і ж
певні насос прийняті
законодавчі не заганяють на
юридичні якісь документи тому
мені здається це не зовсім ну вона ж
громадянська Росія вона розуміє якщо
вона їде в крим які санкції тому
якщо вона була в криму однозначно немає ніг
окупантам треба ставитися як
окупантам ігнорувати і все, і я думаю
що багато країн євросоюзу якби
проводили б у криму, то вони не прийняли
б участь